hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts examining cancer with
men ion methylation and structural
variation presented by Winston 10 PhD
assistant professor department of
biomedical engineering Johns Hopkins
University I am Christina mahalik of lab
routes and I'll be your moderator for
today's events we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by black roots and sponsored
by Oxford nanopore technologies for more
information about our sponsor visit
Manticore techcom before we begin I'd
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and any time he
wants during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the site window just click on
the screen icon located on the lower
right if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
tech I will now turn the presentation
over to him dr. tech the floor is yours
hi
steena for that kind introduction so
today I'm going to be telling you a
little bit about our work in using the
million Alcor sequencer to try and
characterize two specific elements of
cancer DNA methylation specifically
cytosine methylation and structural
variants or areas of the genome that
disorganised in the process of
carcinogenesis I at the top of the
presentation I'd like to disclose that I
have two patents that have been licensed
to Oxford nanopore technologies who
whose technology I'll be talking about
here and who are sponsoring this lab
through its presentation
so to begin I'd like to describe what is
nanopore sequencing and what when I say
an app or sequence what do I mean so
specifically in the context of this
presentation I'm describing the
technology developed by Oxford nanopore
which consists of a biological course
specifically CSG G as picture in the
bottom left here which is a very small
of biological or less than one nanometer
in diameter when you thread DNA through
the pore this affects the current as
pictured in the middle there and you can
actually using differences in the
current you can determine what the DNA
sequences this is a really the secrets
of the day produced is quite small and
keep it in the palm of your hand it
plugs into a standard computer via a USB
port and it can generate Pernell port
flow cell on the order of 26 Giga bases
or three cents billion bases of sequence
data how does the sequence of work well
the basic concept is similar to that of
a culture counter so the co-founder is
this idea for killing cells and
character in cell size you can detect
and you can characterize outfits based
on the blockage of a whole in this case
a nano core but it could be any size
hole with the Coulter counter concept
and the currents the electrolytic
current that's flowing through the ionic
current flowing through most nanopore
work is easier performed with ion
channel proteins like helping in the
licen MSP a or CSBG
or it's an fabricated so can nitride or
graphene membranes
most of the work that done with nanopore
sequencing nowadays is still focused on
this thing
exactly what's in the pour based on both
the duration how long things are saying
in the part and the level of the current
blockade events help what with the
current levels so to sequence DNA on the
Oxford nanopore instrument we need to
make what's called the sequencing a
library to do that we start with high
molecular weight nice long pieces of DNA
break it up a little bit just to make
things a little easier
and then we clean up the ends and then
add specific sequencing adapter these
adapters contain a motor protein which
allowed the DNA the rain of DNA motion
through the Nano cord to be controlled
it also helped there's also a tether
that gets attached which helps to bring
the DNA down to the poor when you add
DNA to the to the core flow so you want
to get it to the poor as quickly as
possible and so if we tether it to in
this case a bead that gets delivered to
the poor effectively then we're that
much closer they're poor and we can get
our results that much quicker picture in
the top right corner is an image from a
typical from the computer a instrument
connected to the the Oxford nanopore
instrument and what you see here is the
sort of typical response where you see
pores the on the pocket or 12 pores
available at any given time for
sequencing we see that 252 are in Strand
so to speak there's a strand of DNA
actively going through the pore that's
the bright green the slightly darker
green color indicates pores that are
open but don't have a piece of DNA in
them right now and then there are areas
where we there's zero currents of the
port block they're not operational or
the pores are saturated in in either
light blue or dark blue so those those
are areas which aren't working so well
this is sort of looks like a typical bun
so changing gears a bit let me give you
a brief description of what do I mean by
structural variation I talked about I
said my talk at the top of the of the
presentation was going to partially be
about structural variation structural
variation is an abnormally a relatively
large region of a chromosome anything
into the city between 50 bases
up to three mega bases or three million
bases this is pervasive in cancer it
turns out that 50% of pancreatic ductal
carcinoma is your pancreas cancer the
most common type of pancreas cancers
have structural variations they're
common in tumor suppressor genes in
genes which normally keep cancer from
progressing like CN T V K and n to a P
16 and CeMAT 4 so what this means is
that when you get variations we get
chunks of these genes getting deleted or
however chunks of chromosome getting
inserted into these genes or or
duplications or or differences in
variation you're going to have problems
because those genes aren't going to
operate in the normal fashion and that's
partially how cancer can develop um
shortly in sequencing so the dominant
sequencing of the time of the common
error is shorter reads either through
thermo Fisher zion's borns answereth or
maluma sequencing both of these
leadlinks are unlimited - on the order
of hundreds of base pairs at the most -
by 300 or 400 base pair reads this is
great for detecting small mutations but
for does that resolve in structural
variations kind of hard because
structuration tend to be in relatively
repetitive areas of genome and you'd
like to have a sequencing wing that can
stretch across the entire boundary of
where you had the insertion to figure
out the context of where that insertion
is nanopore sequencing end and events
that PacBio sequencing are ideal for
this if though if you have a nice long
lead you can stretch across an insertion
you can stretch across inflation or a
tandem duplication or an inversion and
you can get exactly the context and
resolve that structural variant very
effectively so with the advent of long
lean sequencing technologies and their
recent increasing yield of the long wait
sequencing technologies we're we're at
the forefront of be able to detect and
characterize these structural variations
that are occurring in cancer one problem
is that that yield is going up but it's
still limited
you know nanopore sequencing for example
still has only about three to five
databases per cell
for for reference and contents the human
genome human haploid genome so one copy
of each chromosome with add up to
something on the order of three Giga
bases so it means you only have about
one in each region of the human genome
and if you had a heterogeneous sample
sample that had some normal cells and
some cancerous cells you might have some
trouble detecting it you only have one
be covering in two region you want to
have higher depth so you had a
probability of catching the Turks
ovarian luckily there are methodologies
to zoom in and capture only specific
regions in the genome I'm going to tell
you a little bit about our efforts in
one of these methods specifically an
agilent solution-based hybridization
capture so Agilent Technologies is the
company which produces among other
things how do these hybridization
capture baits what's called baits and
and kids so let me walk you through this
procedure you start with genomic DNA uh
you then put on adapters you sort of
break it up and put on adapters to
various sizes then you use in case of
Agilent excellence kits you use an RNAi
bait which is a short on the nucleotide
which is anti sense which will hybridize
which will you know the A's will match
to tease acetyl meant to tease and bind
on to some of your genomic DNA sure but
it will only bind on in the areas that
we care about so we design our probes
our baits very carefully so they're only
in regions around say for example p16 a
gene that we know has lots of structure
variations in cancer you then would use
a magnetic bead which will bind goodbey
baits and you can pull out with the
magnetic bead just the DNA molecules
that you actually care about then you
can wash away the rest and just sequence
what remains and so now I can sequence
in a targeted fashion just the parts of
genome I care about at multiple high def
the trick was when we try to do the
approaches that most these technologies
are optimized for shorter reads and for
fragmenting DNA to on the order of
hundreds of bases and we weren't sure
how well was going to look for longer
molecule so we've Angela we developed we
wanted to develop this method to target
something on the order of two thousand
bases long
our first trial we used talc ropes
approach that just marched across our
entire region and relatively against
tile they'd be close together together
we targeted p16 which is in the region
around it basically one one and a half
million bases of sequence in and around
the p16 region we use relatively low
stringency probes so probes that matched
pretty well but but they match perfectly
a good match a bunch of different
locations of the genome because we want
to make sure we want to pull down as
much DNA as possible in this first round
but as a result we found them to a
really low percentage on target only
about two and a half to a quarter
percent of our reads were actually in
the beacon we want them to be the rest
of them were elsewhere in juice so this
was no good I went back to the drawing
board and for trial two we didn't use
Thailand instead we actually we knew
that we had big molecules and they're
trying to pull out so we could keep our
spaces pretty baby
there's no idea one problem per about
two thousand bases long because you know
the piece would pull down we beat you
down the bases so it would still stretch
across we took we in this case we
actually were able to target because we
need fewer probes we could target to
bridge it so we forget in p16 cdkn2a and
we also targeted some at four we use
really high strategy probes so probe
that we're really unique and and
sequences that you couldn't really find
it elsewhere anything champ and make
sure that we would only get the regions
or hopefully only get the reasons we
cared about we did this in consideration
of no instructional variation
breakpoints we then applied this to
pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma again
the most common form of pancreas cancer
samples from Jabez women's one of the
researchers here at Johns Hopkins the
result was and we got about 30% of our
sequencing reads more on target we're
right where we wanted to be this was as
I mentioned use what's in collaboration
with some of our associates Agilent
specifically Josh wine so our targeting
sequence from performance was actually
quite good using here I'm showing you
here a control which was a na12878 which
is the limbo glass cell line which has
been
highly characterizes one of these DNA
samples that everybody likes to run
their techniques on the first time
because we know almost everything about
it in sequence by every technology you
can imagine we tried it with both
Illumina sequencing and with nanopore
sequencing and what pictured in the top
light is an image showing you the
coverage the number of reads we had per
per base that mapped into these regions
and you see that the sort of light blue
rectangle indicates the region we wanted
to capture for this mad port region what
you see in the red is the nanopore
coverage and what you see in blue with
the Illumina coverage you see that they
both echo each other pretty well and the
coverage is pretty uniform across the
thing it's jagged yes and there's
regions where the coverage seems to drop
out but that's because we didn't have
probes that were high strength with the
design of that region the table below
shows you a summary of these results we
for the Illumina the data we sequenced
on the order of four point four million
beats and these major short leads three
point seven of those 4.4 million were on
target so our on-time percentages for
Illumina sequencing looks quite high
eighty-five percent this was a full
enrichment of 640 fold enrichment over
what you would expect normally I'm just
Tony you know and gave us a coverage of
about 113 X nanopore sequencing in
contrast wasn't a great target percent
only about 30% on target and as you know
we only had 107 thousand reads this was
from a slightly older nanopore
technology now available you can get
higher yield nowadays but I want to
present these results to show you does
30% on target about 3 to 50 X fold
enrichment which results in about 30x
coverage that's pretty good coverage is
reaching we can say with some confidence
where structural variants and what's
going on its region so I'm pretty
excited by that and similarly we did the
same thing for the pancreatic ductal
adenocarcinoma sample and we got about
the same on target percentage with a
really good phone enrichment and there
uncovers going lower because we have
fewer reads
but it was still quite good so what can
we do with this nanopore data um well
what we can do is we can look at we can
look for structural variation we look
for areas which are different so I
using the na12878 cell line we then used
our antenna poor data aligned it or
matched up where it lay in the human
genome and then we try to detect
structural variations with a piece of
software called sniffles which would
develop by on my chats plan who is of
Johns Hopkins and Cold Spring Harbor uh
and sniffles detected a tandem
duplication here I stones light in the
slightly darker red in the in the middle
of the in the middle of the quad here so
I'll Circle it this is a similar
duplication that was detected with deep
PacBio sequencing data from the genome
in a bottle project from Mount Sinai
School of Medicine this is the project
where I I mentioned earlier anyone's
weight 7/8 and have been sequence by
every technology you know the man PacBio
data was also able with its long waits
to detect this sequence in quotes so we
this duplication has been validated and
we could pick it up with our target and
capture another example but this is in a
novel set in the novel sample to pankot
pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma cell
line we found a new structure variation
that we didn't see but we did Illumina
sequencing of this sample using our
nanopore data so what's pictured here on
the y-axis shows individual reads as
different rectangles but you see in
these reads here on the bottom that you
don't you have a big gap in the middle
that gaps actually a place of the part
of the genome that got deleted in this
cancer sample it's not everywhere you
see at these these reads up here have
don't seem to have that same deletion
remember we have two copies of every
gene so this seems to be a heterozygous
or a partial deletion so either some of
the cells in the sample had the deletion
and some didn't or perhaps one of the
alleles lost loss that lost the head of
delete in this area and the other allele
did not so sniffles and and with the
sniffles software with the design of
probes that we had doesn't detect all
possible structural variations what's
pictured here is in red the NI one two
eight seven eight coverage across this
region
p16 a specific region p16 and in green
is the pan correct up that would be
little carcinoma example and what you
see here is that we detected a novel
structural variant just by sort of
observation that you have zero coverage
in this region for the PDAC sample
whereas in the na12878 we do have
coverage what this suggested is that
that region won't delete it but the
region was so large note that it is in
excess of four hundred kilobases long so
horrid thousand bases long we don't have
any reads which happened to come up to
the border know that right before you
get that border we had a drop-off in
coverage coincidentally because the
power probes were designed so we just
didn't have any sequencing reads that
happen to stretch across this deletion
so we did not cover the breakpoint and
so we could not detect this deletion
with okay that we can pick it up by just
looking at coverage luckily and there
are methodologies to do that but symbols
is designed that to only detect things
that you find from great points at least
the version we use so manual examination
and software which looks for copy number
variation or gaps in coverage can pick
these up in with our capture methodology
you can still see these so taking a
slight left inside typical short lead
sequencing is very accurate it's 99.9%
accurate in terms of on a single base
level they have a point sequencing as
you may have heard is not necessarily
that accurate the rough the the raw
accuracy of base called beta probably
less around 90 percent 90 92 percent
depending on on how you how you look at
it the quality of the DNA you put again
etc but embedded in the electrical
signal that you happen to know for
sequencing is more data there's more
information so what we want to do is we
want to go back into the electrical
signal and try and parse out and tease
out what's there and the and we think
we'll be able to get a higher accuracy
will be able to call even down to the
snip level what the results are um this
is software that was actually developed
by a gerund Simpson at the Ontario
Institute for cancer research one of our
collaborators he felt the software
before we even started working together
specifically to be able to correct to go
back in and get better genome assemblies
and be and be able to call even down to
the snip level what the data is relying
on partially on the actual electrical
signal evolving from the metaphor so
what what essentially happens is that
you input the sequencing data and you
use a hidden Markov model which I'm not
going to go into it in great detail here
to determine what's the right answer you
know as in DNA involvement electrical
signals coming off the pork is it
actually a G or is it is it really a
seed looking at the reference sequence
of the human genome we can then actually
determine what the muna type is what the
answer is even down to this nip level so
we tried this has been applied to a
public data set as published by Jane at
all currently as a pre printed bio
archive of na12878 and had pretty high
genotype accuracy at all nights
99.2% that's pretty good and invariable
site sites where it's horrific it was
ninety four point eight percent accurate
so again we tried to apply it to our
capture data as pictured here so let me
walk you through this slide and the top
left you see a region of chromosome nine
which would part of our captured beach
in the purple squares at the very top
there are the true somatic nuclear
variations or our source snips areas of
single base saw alteration I also
pictured here the results we got from
doing the Illumina sequencing in capture
of this region you see that we got six
of six right and no false so the six
indicates the number of true positives
and that the zero in the case number of
false positive so you didn't get
anything wrong and it got all six right
pre Nana polished just using the raw
nanopore sequencing data we only got
four right and we got three that aren't
really there because of the nanopore
sequencing sort of error rate but after
going back to the raw electrical signal
we were able to correct some of these
and and and look not knowing not telling
the man Amash what when where does this
work it was able to go in correct the
data and look to see what the snips what
the actual
accurate sequences using the fact that
we know what the reference is and we
know what we should be looking and we
got actually six correct there and -
incorrect so that's pretty good we and
and looking at it over the entire region
as shown in the bottom right table after
Nana polish we have a precision of about
93 percent in calling the tips and
sensitivity of about 26 percent this is
not that dissimilar from the Illumina
data covering the same region the
sensitivity and you know sensitivity
refers to you actually picking up
position says how many neurons you're
right since anybody says how many times
can catch it at all so we didn't really
catch it some one time but that's again
due to how we designed the probe so
we're going back and trying to do better
design approach make sure we really
capture the region in depth but the
important aspect to realize about this
is that means that along these to 1 to 2
KB long reads we actually going to get
phased information so shown in the top
right is an image generated from igv
which is a sequencing visualization
software and there what you can see is
sort of a snip snip so on the left you
see each row is a different sequence
agreed you can see that we're calling
this homozygous snip a difference from
the reference human genome accurately
that most of the reads after nano
polishing are called correctly as as
orange which is I forget what letter
that is but it's a different letter in
the reference in contrast you can look
at this other area to the to the right
where we have a heterozygous snip and
you can see that we have areas where
there is no snip and then on on the
first two areas and then there is a snip
here on the right side similarly we have
areas where there's this snip and this
snip but nothing here so we're actually
getting phased information on cross
stretches of the genome this is amazing
because this means for the first time
we're going to be able to get long
phased read information in specific
targeted regions typically there has to
be imputed from correlation it's usually
not so hard because you only have to a
wheel so you can figure it out from the
liver today
but it's nice that we can actually
stretch across the entire region and get
phased information because we have these
long leads and we're getting that on the
emphasize we're getting here at the same
time as we're getting the structural
variant information so we'll be able to
identify what allele if any these
structural variants are on with them
with we think with the company so
closing the apparent that the discussion
about structural variation we now want
to move to talking a little bit about
epigenetics and methylation so as
somebody who works in epigenetics I'm
contractually obligated to show the
figure here on the right which is an
epigraph from Washington from 1940
giving us the historical definition of
epigenetics which is how genotype have
your genes your genetic sequence
interacts with the environment to create
Dino types so the analogy is that you
have a ball rolling down a hill so
you're when your stem cell your serve up
here as you roll down the hill you
become differentiated in the genotype
sets up the hills instead of the
structure of the landscape and the
environment decides that you're over in
this valley or in this valley one or the
other
and causing you to become windy it's
commit and become a brain cell or a
liver cell or lung cell or stomach cell
what Valley the ball rolls into it's not
necessarily predetermined but longer
stochastic behavior the image that you
like to use to illustrate that is this
cat rainbow which is actually the first
cloned cat and you can see that this cat
doesn't look like the parent at all in
terms of coloration I know it stochastic
variegation but the point here is that
the variability you have in in phenotype
there is some element of probability in
determining what that is and what modern
definition of epigenetics involves I
usually set as heritable changes other
than the straight genetic sequence which
which is say positive feedback loops
higher order structure where DNA is in
the nucleus actually mares be maze at
the periphery of the nucleus versus in
the center
DNA the periphery usually isn't
expressed in DNA or in the center of
nucleus is more expressed chromatin
organization whether it's it's closed
and chromatin or whether it's more open
chromatin so it can be accessed and
expressed and finally DNA methylation
which is one I've talked about
in mammals in humans DNA methylation
usually occurs in the context of CGI
nucleotides so it can be palindromic and
then regulated after semiconservative
replication the analogy I like to make
is to a computer system where the DNA
sequence is sort of like the hardware
the user input is like the environment
systems biology is like the running
programs and the epigenetics is like the
RAM it's like the active memory it tells
the cell you're a brain cell you're a
brain cell your stomach cell your thumb
so it's just constantly telling it to
itself so it knows you know taken out of
environment what it's supposed to be
doing so can we look at DNA methylation
with well two groups showed that you in
fact could back in 2013
yet school at school and Mark Atkins
group demonstrated that with research
pores not without true nanopore that you
were able to see changes in current
evolving over time as from a methylated
base from methylated cytosine versus an
unventilated sizing so shown on the left
you think shown on the left is a the
current for a methylated sequence in red
versus the unmethylated sequence in
black you can see a relatively
significant change in the current and
the same is shown over here on the right
where you can see the profile for a
methylated cytosine versus the
unmethylated cytosine the current
profile looks essentially different so
what we did in our recent paper that was
published in the spring of this year and
their methods is we with Jared Simpson
we implemented a classifier for
detecting 5-methylcytosine using Oxford
nanopore data so the first thing we did
to do this was we measured distributions
of current for different Kaymer
me coli so nanopore sequencing works by
detecting not one base at a time but
several bases that time so we looked at
the currents that you see from running
for example aggtca
rapport versus TG and TCGA GT rapport so
the the interesting base here is this
scene the second-to-last see in this in
that tamer and this first in the second
see in this cave so what I want and we
did this with two different
chemistry's that Oxford
developed paper took a while to get out
so we started with the so-called version
7.3 por which has since been deprecated
and then we also perform this on the the
r9 tor which a derivation of which is
now in use and nine point four and the
nine point book war is shows similar
results to what I'm showing you here so
what I want you to note is that the the
unmethylated data current distributions
are shown in red and the methylated
current distributions are shown in green
and what you can see is that for some
k-mers we see a pretty significant
difference in current so for example
here we see that there's a big increase
in the amount of current for methylated
unmethylated okay Marcy where this is
physically significant you probably
picked this up pretty easily in contrast
when this came up the current difference
is really small when we looked at the r9
poor which is a smaller port that's you
know someone man leader aperture we find
that we still see a pretty big
difference in this camera
although the distributions generally are
wider but the difference and now we're
even able to pick up the difference in
this camera although it's still pretty
weak and nuts there's clearly a
difference there so this gave us lots of
enthusiasm to move forward we then so
then we applied what's called a hidden
Markov model to try and distinguish what
was happening here essentially what we
do is we go through because then the
Horde is reading multiple bases at a
time we start with for example tigt si
se si the middle point that advances
allows the DNA to advance from one base
through you then have to end up with
either t AG TC a AG TC c AG TCG etc and
so you sort of have a guess at what this
has to be and then you also know what
the current has to be so you can combine
those two probabilities to maximise sort
of the joint probability and you can
trace the most probable path through the
sort of network this Markov chain to
figure out what the right answer must be
when we do that considering whether it's
more likely for a
in position to be methylated or
unmethylated and we estimate what's
called the log likelihood ratio so we
take the probability that was methylated
and we divide that by the probability
that was unmethylated then we take the
log if that ratio is more than 2.5 so if
it's more than you know two hundred fold
likely that was methylated that
unmethylated do we call it the play if
it's more than two hundred fold likely
that it's unmethylated we call it a son
that played it was between those you can
say we don't know this was sort of the
threshold that we set for ourselves to
be to give us a confidence that we
really knew that would methylate or not
so when we apply that to again our good
friend na12878 lymphoblast you DNA we
found that equality really well with the
sort of gold standard for methylation
characterization which is whole genome
bisulfite sequencing so pictured here is
the data for the 7.3 port on the left
and there are nine poll on the right for
comparing any ones we need seven eight
sequencing in in these in CPG Island you
know in Regents of ncg and what the
overall level of methylation was in
these regions bring these samples and
you see we got a correlation of about
one point eight three four seven point
three and point eight four four are nine
so we realize in the course that most of
these gene promoters are unmet elated in
human samples so our correlation is
pretty good it agrees with the
conventional data here's another piece
of information so it's showing that
correlation so published at the same
time as us was a paper from better than
a patent where they showed they had a
different methodology and we publish
back to back to the same issue every
different methodology for classifying
methylation so picture on the left is
their methodology on the right is ours
and you can see that both of them show
very good correlation between bisulfite
sequencing
methylation levels and nanopore
sequencing methylation levels ah I also
want to note this is from again Jane's
bio archive preprints where they had
dense
public relatively dense they in excess
of 20x coverage of the any one to eight
days that this is part of
for show where they just threw a lot of
sequencing at that sample to get
relatively deep sequencing and you can
see that we correlate really well when
we get the deeper sequencing levels our
correlation is it's quite good but the
with the conventional bisulfite
sequencing data when we looked at our
own na12878 data and we we decided to
try and bin it to it to compare it to
transcriptional start site so we could
sort of see if we see the same kinds of
profile typically as shown with the
black line here by self ID data
indicates that methylation dips as it
gets close to a transcriptional start
site and then as it goes back into the
gene body it rises up again as it goes
further away from the transcription
start site upstream gene it typically
goes up again we see that same kind of
behavior for both for nanopore
sequencing methylation data for both the
7.3 and the r9 part we also want to run
some control samples so we took some
human DNA and we made all the C G's
methylated automatically and we made all
the C G's under plays the PCR and that's
pictured here for they have completely
methylated and here for the completely
unrelated
alright whereas they completely Meckler
I really mean about 95 percent
methylated measured by myself by
sequencing we then measure how actor are
we actually calling this how much of
times we get the so called completely
methylated DNA right and how much of
times we get the completely under the na
right so the 7.3 por with 91% accurate
percentage rate we're only confident
about calling 68 percent of the CG sites
because of the log like the threshold we
were setting button get
91 percent accurate of those for the r9
poor we were 94 percent accurate at 77
percent of the sites so this is pretty
good in pictured on the bottom right
here is an ROC curve of that same data
sort of showing you our true positive
versus false positive Braden this is
this is a pretty nice curve showing you
that we can we're pretty confident in
the accuracy of our methylation calls
you think nanopore sequencing so I then
want to sort of tell you briefly about
our efforts in the regime of cancer
sequencing with this methodology so we
wanted to try and apply this
yes sir but yield as I mentioned before
was still no low so we used a an enzyme
to cut up the DNA and kept the fragments
that were between 3.5 and 6 kb this
allows us to keep only about 12.5
megabases
I think you know I suppose they're both
the Giga bases so we can focus our
sequence again giving us on the order of
10x coverage the sequencing runs we did
from these samples we sequenced a
fraction but both nanopore sequencing
and with bisulfite Illumina sequencing
and that's pictured here on the left
hand side so you can see that we see the
same DMR differentially methylated
region with bisulfite sequencing as we
can also resolve with nanopore
sequencing other than that the profile
looks pretty similar with myself I and
Anna put the absolute levels are a
little bit different but generally the
profile looks similar pictured here on
the right is an image this is where it
gets a little bit more exciting it's
image of individual nanopore sequencing
reads in that stretch across the same
region as pictured on the left so the
left is a summary up for all the reads
what's the percent nut lid but here why
does I've broken that up on the right
and I'm showing you excuse me individual
reads as each row and the colored dots
indicate if it's methylated and blue or
unventilated inbred and what I want to
especially draw your attention to is
this area here where the differentially
methylated region is so you can see in
the normal samples as you sort of expect
in the normal samples which are the
green NC f10 a which is a non which is
relatively normal ish cancer cell line
and then the aggressive cancer cell and
the NB a and B - so they want which is
in orange so here this top one is the
normal cell line you can see that a lot
of this region seeds B unmethylated a
lot of red dots and we see that same
thing over here in the percentage and we
see relatively unpopulated bisulfite
when we go down to the cancer sample you
definitely see more blue but what I
wanna draw your attention to is these
these reads here color the red note that
it's not just that you're getting an
increase in methylation here in the did
here in the differentially methylated
region instead it looks like this entire
Reed is pretty blue in the entire when
you gonna place so that entire mom
you'll in a non local way got a got an
increase in methylation this might say
something interesting about what's
happening in the epigenome of cancer
samples and that there's entire
stretches of the genome they're getting
aberrantly methylated and heretofore
it's been hard to see that because we
only had small meeting so we could only
capture you know this piece and then
this piece and we didn't know that these
patterns were correlated over long
stretches so I'm sort of excited about
this this is obviously preliminary
immunity working on it but but I think
we're going to be able to get some
information out about that moreover with
nano polish you can get the snips and
the methylation on the same long lead so
we can see this is again drawn from the
high coverage na12878 public data set we
can see areas which have a snip a Herron
tip exhibit so shown here and you can
see that this top haplotype which has
the snip so you have a lot of
methylation so methylation is is either
these black rectangles or these sort of
pictured here or a sort of lighter gray
rectangle as pictured here and you can
see that for this when you have this nip
this allele of the any one to eighty
seven eight seems like it was highly
methylated whereas this allele down here
at the bottom does not seem to have that
same high level methyl is you can see
that whereas like this region here is
methylated this region isn't this region
is all very methylated this region isn't
so we're seeing allele specific
methylation your dad's copy of the
chromosome might have been methylated
where's your mom's was it or vice versa
to finally really get at not using these
long reads we might they'll get at long
range parents of allele specific
populations and we're excited about that
well another step another direction
we're going with this methylation work
if we're gonna expand this to not just
see T's the way we train is the way we
taught our model right now was to look
pretty much only at CG methylation you
want to expand that we also want to
expand to looking at non methyl cytosine
methylation so no one look at GATC
because we think that we're gonna be
able to use that for exogenously blend
of DNA and be able to label like where
DNA is the nucleus and whether it's open
or closed competent so we're excited
about that and we wanted to also applies
the real clinical samples to get not
just so much when I think out some
tissue
and sequence that with Nana part so I'd
like to acknowledge some of the people
who have worked on this project people
from my own lab myself Rachel workman
Stephanie how you've been planet and
Isaac Lee people from Jim national woods
lab who have worked with us on detecting
and talking to us about structure
variations in providing some of the
sample Jim himself and Alexis Norris we
since graduated and then of course our
great collaborators at the Antarian
super cancer research Jared Simpson
leading the efforts there who has done
look the development of the software of
the nano power software so we can
actually classify this methylation data
and then some of people working with him
Terry David in there see and then
finally I'd like to also thank our
collaborators at agilent technologies
that have helped us with the capture
methodology and into that work i've also
like to acknowledge some of our funding
sources both from within johns hopkins
internally and also from the nhgri for
secrets and technology development
thanks and i'm happy to take questions
thank you doctor attempt for that
informative presentation we will now
start the key a lot of Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on your screen and click on the send
button
well enter as many other questions as we
have time for so let's get started our
first question of the day asks can you
detect methylation with targeted capture
method that's a great question so the
question was can you detect methylation
with the targeted capture method so
short answer no currently and the reason
is because when you're capturing such a
small part of the genome you know a mega
base or so that's one one thousandth of
the genome when we put you know a
microgram or so of DNA into that and
these we're only saving a thousandth at
best if we had 100 percent efficiency so
we'd only have something like an anagram
of DNA back out that's just not enough
with our current methods to sequence so
we have to do some PCR some polymerase
chain reactions and amplification what
that means is that you've eliminated the
methylation marks and so we can't do a
native methylation we need to put in
sort of raw DNA right from the cells to
be able to look at the methylation marks
if you do PCR the methylation gets a
trace so because of limitations in our
cache methodology right now it's not
possible if we can put in more material
or if we can get our library property
preparations more efficient so we could
sequence from say an anagram we could do
it so I'm confident it will be possible
in the future but right now it's not yet
possible
thank you for your answer our second
question of the day asks can you capture
larger molecules than 2 KB great
question so the answer is yes we have
already shown in work I didn't present
today that we can capture out to 5 5 KB
5 thousand bases long but and we're
still striving to get it longer we think
there's going to be some limit where
it's going to become too difficult to
successfully capture and how keep our on
target percent it's keeping a number of
things that map to the right area to
capture the right DNA that's gonna
become hard and getting longer and
longer but and there's also gonna be
diminishing returns from how long we
really need to capture but we think we
can definitely get longer than - we're
confident we can get 5 we're hoping to
get 10 KB long thanks for the question
for the answer look Austin's we're
running a little short on time today
we'll only have time for one last
question and this question asks can you
detect 5-hydroxymethylcytosine with your
methylation classifier that's a great
question so we hydroxymethyl cytosine
for those who may not know is another
type of mark that has recently been very
interesting because it may be part of
the loss of methylation pathway it's
also frequently found in in neurons and
in stem cells so it's it's a mark that's
very interesting and currently hard to
classify with conventional methods I
expect that we will be able to find that
and in fact in in the the the paper that
was published at the same time SARS the
back-to-back paper from UCSC they showed
that in fact you can detect
hydroxymethyl cytosine with Oxford
nanopore data so the answer is yes our
class putter doesn't yet do it we're
working on getting a nice training
methodology to do that but the answer is
definitely yes it's possible
we just need to train the trick is
generating the right training set so we
can be able to say with confidence where
the hydroxy methyl cytosine is and if
the molecule does have hydroxymethyl
cytosine methyl cytosine or a
normal-size c we think that pretty much
more globally we think that pretty much
any modification that DNA is potentially
detectable because it's going to change
the de molecule that's actually in the
core and therefore change the current so
we think we're going to be able to see
all sorts of different modifications the
DNA or even RNA it's just a matter of
training and figuring out what kind of
currents you see from those different
modifications thanks for the question
well thank you for all your answers I
would like to once again thank you I
thank dr. Tam for his presentation I
would also like to thank lab roots and
Oxford nanopore technology is for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through January of
2018 you will receive an email from
labyrinth letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues convey it miss today's flame
events that's all for now thank you for
joining us here at lab roots and we hope
to see you again soon goodbye